hello everyone welcome to today's
broadcast the art of greeting laboratory
zebrafish I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found like clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window I would now
like to introduce today's speaker
Christian Lawrence Christian Lawrence is
currently the aquatic resources program
manager at Boston Children's Hospital
mr. Lawrence also serves as a faculty
member for the health and colony
management of laboratory fish course at
the Mount Desert Island Biological
Laboratory and was a Fulbright
specialist at the bar Eamon University
Faculty of Medicine in sponsz Israel in
2013 I will now turn it over to
Christian for his presentation thank you
thank you Judy so and hello everybody
today I'm going to speak to you about
the art of breeding laboratory zebrafish
so without any further ado let's begin
so as many if not most of you are very
well aware the zebrafish model has been
growing at a normal stress furyk rate
over the last two to three decades and
the trends are such that this growth
will continue with looking at almost
linear growth and the usage of the model
we've gone from a situation where fish
model was used only for early
developmental genetics and now were a
situation where the fish is being used
in almost every single way you
think of a laboratory animal model
species being used in various fields
despite that expansion that vast
expansion in the kinds and scale of
science that we're doing with the fish
the zebrafish much of that science is
still very much reliant on the ability
to produce to get the fish to produce
robust
in predictable amounts of high-quality
embryos for experiments and historically
and for many people that are new to the
model the conventional wisdom is such
that it should be a relatively simple
equation right you put a male and his
female zebrafish together in a breeding
cross and you put them in in the
afternoon typically let them go
overnight and in the morning the magic
happens and you get embryos for
experiments and that's the conventional
wisdom it should be quite easy except
the reality is is that it's anything but
simple it's not a simple question and in
fact it is enormous ly complex so this
question as to whether or not a fish
will breed or not how effectively they
will breed and how predictably they will
breed and how what the quality of the
embryo is is like all of these things
all of these factors are part of what is
essentially an enormous lee complex
multi-layered problem and the situation
really is is that there are a number of
factors that can impact breeding
nutrition behavior water the physical
configuration of the breeding chamber or
tank you have the management the animals
when they're not in breeding situations
that impacts this the genetic background
and all of these things may be
interacting with each other in different
ways to impact whether or not the fish
are breathing of your breeding
efficiency in general
so this is enormously complex this is a
figure that comes from a paper that was
published a couple years back came out
in 2011 and it was by Dan castronovo and
a number of co-authors and what it was
was this really interesting study which
was essentially you an eight
laughs eight zebrafish facilities spread
out all across the world and what they
were measuring was the impacts of
holding density on spawning on
reproductive performance in zebrafish
and what this figure depicts is various
aspects of spawn performance you have
the number of embryos per spawning event
the percent spawning of success so that
basically means how many crosses did you
set up how many of those actually were
successful and then you have the percent
viability of the embryos and you have
the results for at least eight laps and
what you can see at different densities
at 3 6 3 fish per liter 6 fish per liter
at 12 fish per liter this is not
necessarily pertinent to this discussion
but what I want to highlight here is the
spread in the data if you look at this
data across all of these performance
measures you really see an enormous
spread in the data depending on what lab
you're talking about or you're looking
at and the reason for this is that the
only thing that was controlled in this
experiment was the age of the fish and
the frequency with which the animals
were actually bred that in addition to
the densities
everything else wasn't controlled so the
genetic background wasn't controlled the
diet wasn't controlled the way that in
which the fish were reared wasn't
controlled the breeding apparatus that
was used was not necessarily controlled
so these things all varied we recorded
all of these things in this study or as
our lab at Children's Hospital also was
a participant here but the point that I
want to make here is that you had this
enormous spread in the in reproductive
performance that could be attributed to
all of these different factors
and it sort of illustrates it to me it
will illustrates wonderfully how complex
the interactions of all these different
factors are on reproductive performance
so yes it's not simple it's enormously
complex and it can be daunting and so
what I want to do for this talk is go
through an exercise which sometimes it's
best to sort of parcel all of this out
from the standpoint of troubleshooting
okay so when you troubleshoot breeding
problems it's helpful to take this
stepwise approach particularly with
respect to this multi-layered complex
problem as we've outlined and so what
I'm going to do is take you through this
exercise with the hope of outlining some
of the factors that impact reading in
the hopes that it can one help you
design successful breeding programs at
your own institutions or facilities and
to so we can potentially help you work
through problems that will invariably
happen no matter what no matter how good
you are at maintaining laboratory
zebrafish
you will always encounter issues with
breed it's part of the environment part
of the landscape and your ability to
understand how these factors interact
with each other in a stepwise way I
think really it can be really helpful
and so that's what I'm going to do for
the rest of this talk so the first
question that typically I am asked and
I've been doing this for 15 years and
I'm asked the following question well
all the time it's been thousands of
times that have been asked this question
over the years why aren't my fish
breeding okay so the first thing I do
when people ask me that question is I
ask them a question that question is
this do the females in question so this
group of fish that you are having a
particular issue with do those females
have eggs this is a really key question
that can start the breakdown of this
particular sort of way of looking
reading problems do the females who
thinks so you should be able to tell
whether or not a reproductively active
zebra fish female zebra fish has eggs
this is a picture this comes from our
breeding protocol that we use here at
Boston Children's and what it shows it's
the fur this isn't the first page of our
breeding protocol and the idea here is
pretty simple
I want people that are using the fish
people are setting up crosses to know
what it looks like
what good reproductive fish look like
fish that are in good reproductive
condition what do they look like in the
key here is females so the female is
obviously at the top in her body shape
is tells you almost everything you need
to know right a body shape is rounded
it's rounded because she is ovulating
and her ovulated embryo eggs eggs are in
her body cavity and so her body cavity
fills with developing all sites she gets
plump from lack of a better way to put
this is a sign that she's healthy she's
reproductively at you in general way is
that zebra fish once they are sexually
mature they will be such they will be
reproductively active period so this is
what you need to look for if you can't
tell the difference between males and
females by body shape don't bother
setting up a cross because it's not
gonna work it's very very low likelihood
that it will work I just want to point
this out it's it's really interesting
this is a paper that just recently came
out in the journal zebrafish
and it's a neat way to sex zebrafish in
another manner it's the typical way that
we tell people with sexy were fishes by
body morphology which we just discussed
and to a lesser extent color but
although the color particularly the
color differences particularly displayed
by males will be impacted to some extent
by diet but this paper describes a quick
way to sex them based on pigmentation in
the pectoral fin breeding tubercles so
when you look at a male fish from above
if you can see in this particular slide
you can see black pigment in the in the
the pectoral fin that is a
distinguishing character females won't
have that so this is an important and
quick way to sets them when they are
sexually mature but I will get back to
that main point if you can't tell the
difference by morphology doesn't matter
so whether or not a female has eggs is
critical to the entire pathway so if the
female has eggs if the answer the
question is yes then typically now
remember I'm just generalizing here for
the purposes of this exercise this is
nature this is a natural system
biological system so there's no gym you
can't make absolute there's no absolute
statement so this is just a way of
looking at it please don't misunderstand
this for me trying to suggest that this
is all going to be ironclad this is a
way of looking at it but females have
eggs if the answer is yes so I went
backwards we typically look at the
problems ie if the females have eggs and
they're not reading the problems that
you're going to work your way through
typically or behavioural if the females
don't have eggs they're not breeding
it's typically environmental so what
we're going to go to do first is go
through the environmental side equation
and the first question is if the females
don't have eggs not breeding - don't
have eggs first questioning you ask is
is the water quality okay the word
quality is the most important
environmental factor that will impact
the health and productivity efficiency
certainly it's going to underlie every
single issue with with regard to
reproduction so the question is is how
does water quality impacts spawning and
the answer is is that it definitely as I
said it's a pervasive thing in an impact
spawning in two ways both long term and
short term long term the question really
is is are your assistent parameters are
the water quality parameters stable
and with annexed with in acceptable
ranges inside your zebrafish housing
systems this is a table that comes from
a book that came out a few years ago a
guide book and what it shows you our
target ranges for zebrafish in a variety
of environmental parameters that you
should be measuring that you should know
when your zebrafish systems what I would
suggest is that if you are outside these
ranges on any of these numbers in any of
these parameters you're gonna have
issues your fish will not breed they're
going to be all of their energy is going
to be involved in maintaining
homeostasis under very challenging
conditions and so any energy that would
otherwise be allocated towards
reproduction isn't going there so the
fish will stop breeding females will
stop producing eggs if any of these
water quality parameters are out of
whack
the other thing I'd say is that you want
stability right so the absolute value
within these target ranges isn't as
important the stability if you are let's
just take for example pH if you're
moving your pH is moving from six point
eight to eight point five within a
single day every day your fish probably
aren't going to be breathing because
that is a lot of environmental
fluctuation that yes they can deal with
it but it's gonna take a lot of energy
away from everything else so you really
want stability within this range pick up
pick a point within this range and stick
to it if that is taken care of then you
can pretty much eliminate water quality
at least long term you also have to
think about how water quality is
impacted short term okay so this is a
picture that comes from one of our labs
children's and this just shows you a
cart that is full of breeding cages
these are static breeding cages not
everyone does it this way but this I
would say if you look at the field in
general this is the predominant way that
zebrafish laboratory zebrafish
are spawned and in research settings in
a static brain chamber and you have to
think about what's happening
in that static cage and some in the
water in terms of the water quality the
fish are continuing to excrete ammonia
across the gills and it will lesser
extent feces and urine and there is no
clean water coming in there's no air
flow water being pushed out so what
you've got is a situation the second
that you put a fish in a static chamber
you've got a deterioration in water
quality and this can impact breeding if
you're not careful about the things you
need to think about relative to this
context are number one you need to make
sure that your densities aren't too high
I'm not going to give you a magic bullet
density but typical for a large zebra
fish and by large I mean a male is
probably half a gram and a female as a
gram and weight those would be large
zebra fish you're not going to be able
to go more than oh maybe two fish a
leader and the lower the density the
better obviously the higher the density
the more accumulate the more that waste
will accumulate faster that conditions
will deteriorate in those tanks and
certainly the accumulation of
metabolites building up over a 24-hour
period it's going to impact reading in a
negative way so you could think about
those densities that's number one so
clearly you can't just you want more
eggs you just can't add animals to a
static grading case you're gonna have a
point where density you're going to hit
that density threshold where waste
productions can become a problem you
also want to be able to reduce feeding
okay so one of the classic problems the
mistakes that I see with people who are
having issues with breeding is that they
will feed their fish a snack a snack yes
a snack when they put them in breeding
cages so they set them up in the
breeding cage as a static container and
then they'll go get a little bit of fish
food and they'll give them each some
fish food so that they're ready to go so
that snack will really fire them up for
a breeding event well that's the
absolute worst possible thing you could
do because all you're going to do is
accelerate the way
production in their tank in the ammonia
production tank and you're not gonna get
any breeding so it's gonna be absolutely
counterproductive you may depending on
what you feed them and how much you may
kill them we've seen that unfortunately
this also gets not just at the breeding
tank itself but also the holding
conditions before you set them up so you
want to try to time a breeding event or
taking fish out for breeding events as
far away from the last feeding as you
possibly can because the further away
you are from it the less waste you're
going to have produced in those tanks so
this is something to think about I would
recommend based on my experience a gap
of at least two hours between when
they've last been fed and when you
actually set them up their own breeding
this will keep the ammonia levels lower
certainly more than two hours this can
be is going to be it's going to be even
better and lastly you can change the
water so there are many people in the
field that will set the fish up in the
cross overnight and then the next
morning before they want the spawn to
commence they will change the water they
will either take the breeding breeding
insert out of the cage and put it in a
new tank of water or they'll just flush
that tank clean water the idea is behind
that is you're flushing the tabloids and
certainly when you see problems that
look like it come into them in the
morning after you've set up breeding
crosses and the tanks look funky change
the water it's certainly not going to
hurt them and it may in many cases help
the situation certainly it's all about
getting those metabolites down so this
is how water quality impacts breeding on
the short term
so once you've sort of gone through this
hole the first step of water quality if
the answer is one quality is not okay
well then obviously you've got to remedy
that situation whether it be long term
making sure your parameters are where
they need to be unstable or short-term
to those things that we just talked
about in terms to make sure
that water quality is not negatively
impacting you your create crossing cages
of crossing tanks in the short term if
you've done that and they still don't
breathe then you go to the next level
okay so what quality is fine but they
still don't breathe and they're not
females don't have eggs so what is it
first question nutrition so if water
quality is number one the most pervasive
environmental factor that will impact
fish breeding productivity 1a is
nutrition nutrition is enormous ly
important and of course I would caution
you because the in my experience working
in this field for a long time
nutrition is the first thing that people
think of no matter what they're always
think of fish I'm getting fed enough the
fish aren't breeding they need to eat
more and you know what in many cases
it's true but you have to make sure that
you're looking at all of the factors
this is part of what we're doing this
exercise for but nutrition is certainly
a big issue there are a number of
different levels of this issue of
nutrition that will impact meeting so
how much food what kind of feed how that
feed is delivered really matters too and
then how you handling this by handling I
mean how are you preparing it how are
you storing it these things are really
impact nutrition and nutrition will look
that greedy so let's look at each one of
these a little more closely in terms of
what to feed what's in it it's all about
what's in that diet okay so one thing
I'll say right up front is that we have
not yet worked out what the precise
nutritional requirements are for
zebrafish
we have some ideas based on some limited
data that's out there we have some ideas
based on other fish you can make some
generalizations and the things that I'll
tell you here are more generalizations
number one the amount of polyunsaturated
fatty acids or so-called ruthless and
highly unsaturated fatty acids a longer
chain fatty acids that you may have
heard of the EPA DHA and arachidonic
acid or AAA these are critically
important in most fish diets whether
they be prepared in particular prepared
diets will be formulated
to contain elevated amounts of these
things because it's important
physiologically important for all fish
for growth and reproduction zebrafish
are no different now zebrafish have
different requirements for the relative
amounts of different kinds of fatty
acids and that's really a little bit
outside the scope of this particular
discussion and we have not yet worked it
out we haven't learnt we have emerging
data that's suggesting what the fatty
acid profile should look like but again
it's outside the scope of this
discussion what I would say for the
scope of this discussion is you got to
make sure that these things are in your
diet okay in most diets again prepared
to have them in them now each diet will
be different in the amounts of these
fatty acids and is something we need to
be looking at vitamins are very very
important vitamin C in particular
vitamin A and D are also been shown to
be really important for zebrafish
reproduction the purity of the diet you
want to know what's in that diet you
also want to know how that varies over
time so ideally you want your diet your
profile your diet to be consistent okay
so these are all the types of things you
need to be looking at with respect to
what's in your diet so it doesn't have
those long-chain fatty acids and an
important reproduction does it have
proper amounts of vitamins key vitamins
particularly C and D but there are
others as well is the purity of the feed
good do you know what the purity is do
you know what the ingredients are and
can you not what's the word I want to
use can you rely on the consistency of
that diet does the profile change
depending on when you buy it it
shouldn't ideally you want something
that is stable and defined pure how much
do you feed them this is critically
important too
we've done studies that have shown that
adult fish particularly growing
reproductively active zebrafish need to
be fed at least 3 to 5 percent of their
body weight per day and this has been
shown to support high rates of
reproduction
okay so in my experience what I've seen
simply that the amount of feed going in
being a big issue for reproductive
performance and I have seen that many
times it's simply that the fish are well
below being fed fed levels of a feed
that's well below is three to five
percent of body weight and I would say
in general that you want to go towards
the higher end of this range if the fish
are really being actively bred all the
time if they're not being actively bred
all the time you can back off of this
and we'll talk a little bit about this
as we go into other subjects related to
this but this is the general range of
how much handling the fish how do you
feed how do you deliver the diet okay so
very simple make sure you're feeding a
dry diet diet a dry diet dry a wet feed
wet
what does this mean particularly with
respect to dry diets I've seen many many
times people liquefying flake feed
pellet feed crumble putting it on
powdered feed putting it in a slurry and
feeding in a squirt bottle that's the
worst possible thing you can do
everything more soluble in that diet
once it gets in the water it's leaching
out of it this can be very very rapid
okay so what you're doing in this in
this particular event if you're
liquefying a dry diet is that you're
basically taking out any of the
nutrients that you're supposed to be
getting into the fish so in order to
make it easier to feed you're actually
feeding something that's less it's not
some it's not it ends up being not what
you think it is okay it's less than what
it should be
you're also feeding directly the system
and this doesn't help or actually does
help the the growth of algae and
cyanobacteria that you definitely don't
want so make sure that you're feeding
the diet properly and delivering that
diet properly last but least you want to
make sure that you're handling the diet
properly with respect to live diets need
to understand how you're culturing them
our team has a great example of this
right so you should understand what
stage your Artemio are when you're
feeding them out so you want to get them
as close to hatching in
general it's possible because this is
when the energy content is highest if
you let them go the longer you let them
go after hatching the less energy they
have the larger they are the more
difficult they are to catch all of these
things impact that so you should really
have a good handle on how your cultures
are behaving good feeding live feeds and
then also with respect to like how
you're storing processed diets make sure
that you're keeping feeds in a cool and
dry place basically heat light moisture
the number one end and most primary
enemies of any processed diet so you
want to make sure that you're not
keeping like a bucket of flake food out
in the fish room at 85 degrees in a
bucket that's being opened continuously
every day I'm putting closed every day
this is going to what's going to happen
in particular is that you're gonna have
some of the other things like your fatty
acids you're launching fatty acids or
one could deteriorate down all the time
what you doing is feeding a diet that
doesn't have what you think it has you
can also get some of the fats can become
rancid so you can actually provide I'm a
better way to put you can poison the
fish so think very carefully about how
you're also storing the fish storing the
field sorry
so turnover for feed is also important
so you should never be buying for four
years worth of feet it's not not gonna
do you any good use two to three months
worth of feed at a time keep that on
hand and turn it over that's a good
practice and then store it according to
manufacturer instructions so all of
those things will impact nutrition okay
so you need to be looking if you're
having breathing problems you want to
look very critically at all of those
things and then once you ensure that
these are not the issues then you can
move on to other and you still having
problems then you can look at some other
factors in the one that I'll bring up
here environmentally is disturbance
disturbance variety of different kinds
of events can lead to gradual reading
cessation so these things are the
chronic things that over time you may
have fish that are breeding females that
are producing eggs and over time they
may not even be that old but over
time they stopped it could be
disturbance okay
one of the major disturbance I'll
categorizes his disturbance is disease
okay so chronic disease will impact
reproductive function either fish that
this particular slide shows fish that
have super low moaner philia okay long
term so these fish are cute cute
clinical presentation of super Aloma i
would challenge you to sex these fish by
eye and in fact if you cut them open and
look at the gonads you're probably not
gonna find it because there's nothing
left these fish have been destroyed by
the pathogen this is an extreme example
long term but you know how many times
I've seen 15 years of working in this
field how many times I've seen people
set fish up like this many they're not
gonna breed and this is the disturbance
in this particular instance is disease
and this is a long-term chronic effects
of disease like certain loma and others
aggression so their housing conditions
so this is a video this is the first
slide that i have i'm not going to play
the video here because it's it's for
simplicity's sake some of you have you
seen me or heard me talk before you may
have seen this video what I'll tell you
at the outset is that I have a youtube
channel that we're gonna push out the
your help for that so you can go to this
channel it has a number of videos this
video is included I can tell you the
name of this video it's called two fish
in a tank this is an example of long
term environmental disturbance in a
sense and in the form of aggression
okay so when you have two fish in a tank
long period long term this is a worse
social situation you can keep an adult
zebra fish in and what you'll see is
that one fish will basically dominate
the other so this video basically shows
you a dominant fish and the subordinate
fish and I can certainly tell you that
the subordinate fish will never breathe
this fish is if it's a female she will
stop producing eggs in this particular
video it's a male but the same thing
happens with females social situation a
long term will
reading in a negative way in this form
is aggression okay there are other
examples of disturbance the noise is a
big one vibration these fish are built
in such a way that they are very
sensitive to vibration so a vibration
that you and I may not be able to detect
these fish are more sensitive to it and
we are so there's construction in your
building your fish were breeding and
then the construction goes on for a
couple months and fish stop breeding you
can't figure out what it is take a look
at the vibration vibration could be part
of it okay
toxicity is a big one so long-term
exposure to toxic compounds in the water
coming emanating from various sources
can also impact reproductive function
over the long term or any other
environmental interacted temperature
changes anything like this over time
these things can impact breeding always
will
so disturbance is a big one okay the
last one I'd say I put in the
environmental category is are the fish
too old or too young so if you've gone
through you've asked this question fish
do they have eggs the females have eggs
they don't and it's not water quality
it's not nutrition there's no
disturbance if you could find alright
let's go to the easiest question are
they too old are they too young maybe
this question can be first but certainly
it's the one that should be asked okay
this is a curved picture that a cartoon
and I made of a typical greeting
efficiency curve received a fish in our
hands and what you can see is from the
age of about a little before three
months all the way to 18 to 20 months
this is the typical breeding age of a
laboratory zebra fishing you can see
that the breeding efficiency is highest
between the ages of nine and twelve
months this is an our hands and this is
what it looks like right this is pretty
typical what I will tell you is that
this curve the edges of this curve can
be moving in either direction depending
on a number of environmental factors so
for instance if you feed
really on the right way right frequency
and you raise them at lower densities
you can get them sexually mature before
two months there are people out there in
the world right now or turning over
generations within 45 days on the other
end of things if the fish are being used
more or less that will impact the length
of the curve on them on the other side
of me the older side right so fish that
aren't used very often will typically
have a longer period of breeding
efficiency than those that are used very
heavily so for instance in our
facilities we use we have populations of
wild type that we are continuously
getting embryos from for to support
various experiments these fish are
always produce their breeding efficiency
goes down faster than fish that are not
used that maybe only are used once to
propagate a line so all of these things
matter but you want to make sure that
the fish are within this breeding is a
typical age of efficiency so this is
comes from a paper that we published a
couple of years back where we looked at
we defined generation time and what we
were able to do was basically we were
able to get fish to breed at 10 fish a
leader within within 60 days okay and we
were able to do this we basically grew
the fish up recorded all the conditions
and when we can tell the difference
between males and females we set them up
for grading crosses okay so that just
before it's 60 days the the first time
when we first could tell a difference
we've got some breed of breeding
efficiency but one week later that breed
so that breeding efficiency was pretty
low one week later it was much much
better so we're around sixty days we
were able to do this but the key here is
that the sexes need to be discernible
again if the females don't have eggs and
they're 2 months old they're too young
it's a simple thing but something you
need to think about and I've had to
parse this out I got to work this out
with people who are asking me why the
fish aren't breeding well maybe they're
not old enough yet on the other end all
fish so this slide is a pretty the color
is not coming
well I'll take you through it this is
these are all fish from the same tank
they're all greater than three years old
okay this male doesn't look so good but
I I would almost guarantee you that you
that he have you put him with a robust
young female he probably is gonna be
able to spawn he's probably gonna be
able to produce viable embryos so males
typically on a longer reproductive
lifespan than do females this females
too old she's producing eggs or was but
she's terminally egg bound she's got a
blockage in a row but not calcified
remnants of retained eggs and we'll talk
a little bit about this on the other
side this presentation this fishes egg
timer she's not gonna breed anymore
she's too old
she's egg bound this female is too old
but she's senescence she's no longer
producing eggs you set her up with this
male you're not gonna get anything you
set her up with a good metal you're not
gonna get anything so the idea is that
you need to be looking at the age on the
old side in general males are going to
be longer term they're gonna be viable
longer term alright so that covers the
environmental piece behavioral okay this
gets back at the other side of the
equation the females have eggs but
they're still not breeding the problems
tend to be behavioural okay so the first
question I asked there is are the
bishops displaying normal mating
behavior okay if the answer is yes the
first question is is are the eggs over
retain are females
egg bound so this is a picture of two
reproductively active female zebra fish
or reproductively we protect early age
females equation should say and the one
on the top is grabbing ready to spawn
she's a she's a prime reproductive
specimen the female on the on the bottom
is egg bound if you set her up she's not
gonna spawn she's gonna try and the
males will try but you're not going to
get anything and this is just a
production problem so females zebrafish
when they're reproductively healthy are
always ovulating
and they need a male to get rid of those
eggs to shut those eggs if they don't
have that amount they're not exposed to
the male what they will do is those eggs
will break down but the rate of envy
resort but the rate of breakdown and
resorption will not exceed the rate of
ovulation so what happens is you get
slow resorption they continue to ovulate
and fill up with eggs eventually you'll
get a plug of the oviduct and you can
get basically a lots of bad things
happen the clinical term is egg
associated Flint inflammation but
basically females need to be managed
such that they don't become egg dominant
so they're gonna be cycled so females
need to be exposed to males on a regular
basis this is really important when
you're isolating females but when you're
keeping them in single sex tanks got to
make sure the females being exposed at
least once a week every two weeks
depending on those conditions and so
those are numerous factors that will
impact egg retention feeding so the more
they're fed the faster they're gonna
cycle so the more they're gonna have to
be cycled with males the frequency with
which they're set up okay so if they're
being actively managed fed for a
reproductive function and then they're
not being bred frequently right or at
all you're going to get egg retention or
retention housing is also going to
impact this so low densities you're
gonna tend to get more fish that are egg
bound particularly if they're not taken
out and spawned in spawning chambers
spawn will happen in mixed sex tanks is
it tanks it's that's interesting it's
recorded for posterity so excellent mix
X tanks low densities they're gonna
spawn but not very efficiently so you're
gonna get a all the retention there as
well and then last but least not least
with this particular issue of housing is
if you some people will segregate sexes
to make sure that there's not too much
breeding tanks this is not something I
typically worry about but
you do we keep our vision makes sex
tanks here to help facilitate some
natural cycling but if you don't keep
them segregated yeah make sure that your
spine so exposure to males is really
important so those are all the things
that are impacting better that are
looking at are involved with egg ovary
tension if that's not the issue
if the gut eggs and then clearly aren't
egg bound but they in there displaying
mating behavior actually sorry
if the fish are not displaying mating
behavior so they have eggs they're not
egg bound but they're not displaying
mating behavior then you've got some
other issues that you can look at one of
them is incompatibility okay so this
idea that female zebrafish are
indiscriminate isn't true in fact they
definitely are choosing okay there are a
number of things that they look that
they're actually evaluating in males one
of them has to do with old-fashioned
this is this clip here comes from a
paper that came out a wonderful paper
that came out a number of years ago that
looked at the impacts of olfaction what
they showed is that juvenile zebrafish
this is before sexual maturity expressed
a strong preference for the olfactory
cues so they were looking at odors and
so they basically had fish in these
experimental tanks where they could
expose that fish to basically older
plumes from other fish and give them a
choice as to go into one part of the
compartment or another depending on what
the smell was okay and what they showed
was that juvenile fish before sexual
maturity always chose to associate with
the odors of kin so familiar fish so
they always chose kin but when they
became sexually mature they showed a
preference to associate with non really
interests and this is definitely the
case females males don't typically care
but females definitely are preferring
the odors of non related individuals
this really has an impact on your
breeding efficiency so it's a big one
and genetic relatedness will be impacted
by the number of things but in a world
where we don't have commercially
available zebrafish that are genetically
diverse people are maintaining their own
stocks within their own facilities to a
large degree and it's a lot of work to
deal with this and to maintain them
properly and many people are either
unwittingly or aren't really thinking
about it are exposing their fish to
bottlenecks okay and so what you get and
you have a genetic bottleneck if you get
inbreeding and you get closely related
individuals so you may have fish that
are reproductively healthy but they're
not really necessarily very attracted to
each other females in particular aren't
driven to drop to mate with the males a
lot of this may have to do with that
genetic relatedness okay so this
generality are more closely related to
fish are the less unique
desire you're gonna have on the part of
the fish it's probably not the right way
to determine but I think it illustrates
the point there's not as much Drive when
the fish are closely related you can
overcome it particularly in the because
the males don't care as much or don't
seem to match to mine whether or not
they're mating with symptom onset but
the females do this is going to impact
your production so if your stocks are
really inbred even if they're
reproductively help you may get low
production incompatibility in general
there are ways to offset it one of them
is mixing and matching so one thing that
will happen in zebrafish tanks is that
they will form social hierarchies that
can be counterproductive to feed it to
breeding okay this is happening with
males and females in one way you can
sort of offset that incompatibility
both in housing tanks that's generated
from these breeding these these
hierarchies were dominant individuals
will suppress reproductive function in
subordinates so you mix and match
housing tanks and you can mix and match
inbreeding crosses so if you've got a
pair of zebra fish that don't seem to
want to spawn you can try it too
present that female with another male
work so mixing and matching is important
in one thing that I'll say it's an
anecdotal but it's certainly
illustrative of this particular issue is
that you could try this experiment at
home alright so if you have several
tanks of a particular strain that are
all the same fish and you keep them in
these tanks for a long period of time
let's say you keep them in these tasty
these individual tanks the sediment
dividual tanks for a month and then at
the end of the month you take those fish
out you mix them up in a bucket and then
you redistribute them randomly in the
tanks the next morning when you come in
more likely than not you're going to see
a lot more breaching activity you saw
before this is because you're mixing and
match to breaking down some of those
hierarchies groove crossing can offset
this female choice as well so again it's
just giving her more choices for
different males that may be more
attractive to her brief segregation can
also help this gets back to this is this
mixing and matching type idea where
again you're just changing the
identities of the fish are holding them
in separate chambers and then mixing
them together this can also offset some
of the incompatibility problems that you
may see in breeding females are also
choosy about spawning sites there are a
couple things as has been shown in both
nature and in domesticated fish this is
a picture that zebra fish habitat
Bangladesh and it's lots of vegetation
so they have been shown both in the lab
in the wild to prefer to spawn in among
the vegetation this is a video that
again I'm not gonna show you could see
this on the YouTube channel but
basically what it shows you is the zebra
fish spawning and almost all the
spawning activity is centered around the
breeding just centered around these
plastic plants that we provided in tanks
so plastic plants inbreeding things can
impact spawning and in in a positive way
gravel is another one they've been shown
to want to prefer to oviposit over
gravel this is harder to replicate in
culture conditions but this really sort
of
this whole age-old approach of marbles
so there are many people whose
information world is still marble their
zebrafish
put them in a some kind of container
males and females I container with
marbles on the bottom and it's over time
over the years has been shown to be
effective yeah this may be part of it
because they do have this preference to
spawn over this kind of substrate also
if shallow versus not a sort of a death
gradient depth grade
so this comes from a very simple set of
experiments where we that we did a
number of years ago at Boston Children's
where we look to see whether or not the
so-called preference of the wild fish to
spawn in shallow area so it's thought
that the fish in nature spawn in in and
around the margins of the water bodies
that they had happen okay so what we did
was we wanted to see if that preference
for spawning in shallow water was
retained and domesticated fish we sent
the fish up and non tilted tanks versus
those that had a death gradient so he
basically gave them a beach right so we
showed was is that you had a much higher
proportion of embryo spawn embryos or
eggs spawned in the shallow water if you
gave them that template okay so that
preference for spawning in shallow
waters is retained even domesticated
fish and typically of what we found in
this experiment is that we got higher
spawning success and also larger
clutches so just by facilitating this
behavioral adaptation or behavioral
preference for the fish we're able to
increase production so this is something
you want to look at as well I can tell
you many times again some of this is
anecdotal but sometimes anecdotes are
good right and so over the time over the
years I've had people talk to me about
having problems with their fish spawning
and I simply change the configuration of
the spawning caged Fisher in giving them
a better place to spawn a beach to spawn
in and they spawn so little things like
this matter
so Richard displaying leaning behavior
it's not a compatibility issue where
they're not displaying mating behavior
and it's not a compatibility issue is it
the technique and this sort of gets at
what we're just talking about this is a
picture of a typical breeding cage at
Boston Children's and this is what I
would say is the right configuration
okay so you've got a shallow zone and
you got a deeper zone where if they're
not ready to spawn they don't spawn and
the males will basically use that cellos
on shallow zone to do a greeting display
a stereotypical breeding display in the
shallow water the females are enticed to
go up in this channel of water and
spawning happens most of spawning is
happening in that shallow water this is
actually still in the video again is
that not on a youtube site that shows
this very very well and also I should
say I never showed you a picture if
you're not familiar with what green
behavior looks like this is it okay this
video will show you very well what green
behavior looks like in a zebrafish so
this is a properly configured tank again
many many times in the history of my
career here working with these fish and
people trying to use these fish to get
the Miss bond just changing that
configuration making that configuration
right makes a huge difference this is a
video that shows spawning behavior or
really not a lot of spawning behavior
when you don't give them a death
gradient so again this is on that
YouTube channel just shows you the
difference when you in behaviors when
you give them the template the ability
to express these behaviors this is a
video that is not on the YouTube site
but I'll put it on there and I'm happy
to you email me I'll send you all these
videos as well this is a video of fish
that are in water that's too shallow
it's shallow all the way around and
they're just freaked out so they're
frozen
freezing is a stress behavior
stereotypical stress response these fish
are not moving a muscle
they're never gonna spawn because it's
not enough water to take
so this morning technique if it's not
that gonna look bad again and lastly a
disturbance there are a variety of
different events that can lead to abrupt
reading sensation so we talked about
disturbance before in the sense that
cried in the idea that it's chronic but
it can also be abrupt and these things
tend to be acute okay so there are
numerous examples noise loud noise
suddenly it's going to like let's say
somebody starts hammer drilling in the
world next-door fish may not breed it
off even though they're their
reproductively ready to do so toxicity
you get a spike of a toxic compound in
the water if it doesn't kill them
they're certainly not going to breed so
chlorine would be a great example of
this but there are many others heavy
metals so on and so forth these things
are going to impact breeding on a short
term and then environmental irregularity
if you shut the lights off typically
these fish are should be on control for
two periods but if someone comes in in
the middle of the night the lights are
off and turned them on or pulses them on
and off a number of times that night
they may not spawn the next morning so
same thing with a temperature drop all
sorts of these kinds of sort of acute
environmental irregularities can be a
big problem
photo period we just talked about that
disease is a huge one okay so I've been
in situations where there's been an
acute outbreak of a disease fish
typically in some cases we've had fish
dying from disease and fish other fish
are still spawning within the same tanks
but if the event is acute enough and the
agent is acute enough they are not gonna
spawn okay so this is something that
could be an issue so if there's some
kind of pathogen that's that's sweeping
through your populations you're gonna
know it anyways
chances are but certainly then it's
going to impact spawning as well in the
short term so what you've got here is
sort of this overview now again what I
hope to have Illustrated to you
over the course of this talk is one how
complex this is it's not a cut and dry
issue - I've hope to have Illustrated to
you that there is a pathway that you
should be following a logical
progression of questions that you should
be asking when you're trying to
troubleshoot green and then finally I'm
hoping that I showed you from this
pathway sort of the relationship between
some of these factors and how they can
impact the overall success of an green
program and those are really my
conclusions so you want to consider all
of these factors you want to work your
way through these problems step-by-step
you start if at all possible from the
simple to the complex don't
automatically think it's some big
picture flashy problem because many
times it's something very very simple so
you really want to go simple to the
complex and then you want to apply new
data as it becomes available so
particularly over the last couple of
years we've been getting better and
better people are starting to look at
factors that impact reproductive success
whether it be diet whether it be
behavior welfare conditions all these
things and how they impact reproductive
success you should be keeping a sort of
abreast of these of these developments
as they come out and then use that
information to help inform your breeding
programs because it might give you this
talk next year I'm going to know more
and the talk is gonna be different okay
and so this should be the more we know
the better we can inform these processes
the better we can work our way through
problems when they come so last but not
least I'd like to thank the organizers
organizers of a conference live lab
roots everybody here at Boston
Children's and then people that have
shared with me materials and information
that I've used in these slides so what
I'd like to close with finally is please
if you have questions related to any of
this do not hesitate to ask me always
happy to answer them now thrilled if you
ask me those questions and send them to
me
always happy to talk so thank you very
much thank you for that informative
presentation unfortunately we are out of
time I want to thank the audience
reviewing today's event see you next
time goodbye